he
んっはいというわけであのタイトルにもあるとおりでございます
私はじめシャツを
まああの非常に厚かましいんだから私
これまで
結構長い期間をチャンネル登録者数日本一の日本一位の
ユーチューバートップユーチューバーはじめ刺そうと
いう名前でねいろいろねそういうそういう二つ名を持ってあの youtube 会で
のこれまで活動をしてきたわけなんですけれども
もう知ってる方も多いと思います
私
日本一のユーチューバーでは
ありませんでした
あの
本当に
なんではいいでしょうね安定ばいいか全くわからんけどとりあえずですねあの日本一だ
と思ってたんですけどにほいちゃう
ないみたいですねちょっとあの詳しく出てるしますはとりあえずいて今まではです日本
一が肇社長
チャンネル登録者数がの878万人兄がヒカキン tv
862万人で3位が専門も ic チャンネル826万人良いがフィッシャーズ640
1万人という感じでこれだったんですけどあの
1位が
キッズラインで一致がですねあの肇社長ではなくキッズラインというチャンネルだった
額です
複雑ですね本当に複雑でしたあのマザー長年
チャンネル登録者数日本人のユーチューバーと名乗ってしまいいい
申し訳ありませんでした申し訳ありませんじゃってわけじゃないんですよねなぜなら
この日本のキッズラインっていうチャンネルですよ何度はるかに何度晴れ者に外れ雪を
凌駕する
800なんて始まりねキッズライン参戦190万人も線200万人
6いったーっいやーこれは無理ださせに何か頑張ってすぐ抜けそうな数字でもないです
ね
僕とかヒカキンさんのはるか300万人ぐらいの上の数字を持っていますねキッズ
ラインサンチャンネル登録者数が110090万人が日本一だったということが最近
明らかになったみたいでございます
はいはじめシャツを
日本終了です
数予定かあのいつから終わってたかもよくわかんないんですけどねでなんでこんなこと
が起きているかといいますとキッズラインさんがチャンネル登録者数を非表示にしてた
らしいんですよなんでかわかんないですけど何でだか今もチャンネル登録者数を公表さ
れてますね
で縛られているチャンネル登録者数が非公開になってたんで調べる方法がなくてあの
かりそめの日本一でした
戦では全然いいんですけどねあの来づらい3どういう道を出しているかといいますと
なんかお茶とか子供向けのアニメとか子供たちが売買してるチャンネルなんですけども
やすごいと総再生回数が95億会とかなんであのまさにチャンネル登録シャル線
190万人に相応し数所を持っていると思います何で隠してて
全然いいです怒ってないいいんですけどいいんですけど今日ねあの
言いたいことがわかりますなんてんでしょあのずつ日本一だなと思ってるんですけども
全然日本じゃなかったというこの不思議な気持ち伝わりますでしょうか
いやー
あっけなかったな俺の転嫁もすぐんなんとはいえ全然来やすいとかそういう感情が
起きるわけでもなく
a みたいな驚きの歓声道が多かったですねでも youtube の公式さんも
チャンネル登録者数が1000万人護衛すると金の再生モダンの上のダイヤモンドの
再生ボタンがもらえるんですけどもそのちゃんとお受け取りになられていたのでもう
間違いないことだと思いますはい
[音楽]
ん
これが日本一を奪われた堕落した男の顔である
はいなんかニュースとかテレビとかでもさんネル登録者数日本一の動画クリエイター
はじめしゃちょーでして紹介されることももうはしばらくないのかなという気がして
おります不思議ねこんなこともあるんですね
いや日本一の9回
恥ずかし恥ずかしいじゃあどっちかというとめっちゃくちゃない具は日本時間持って
行動が沿ってなんですよ全然そんなことないんで何ね所北基本的にあんまりその順位と
か
たランキングとかを気にするタイプではないんですけどもやっぱり1位って言われてる
となんか市稲荷のさあその感じ出さなきゃいけないのあるじゃないですか
それはねやっぱりどうして僕あったんでなんだろうなぁ
若干気が楽になったといいますかまあまあていう気はしますね
なんかすぞきみしないんですけどやっぱ一致の重みというのはまつげなんかあるんでが
頑張んなきゃみたいな
ツイータから絶対をボロいにやろうみたいなそんな空気があると思ってる人は申し訳
ないと思いますけどねああいうあの報告です何か twitter とかでちょいてき
たんで外れ添い乳じゃなかったって読みたいならちょっときたんでこれはもうもっと1
として何か一言コメントを残さなければとも
って今動画を撮っております僕のコメントはただ一つびっくり買えという話をちょっと
いち早く取ろうと思っていま東京でお仕事に来てるんですけどまぁ今の時間でてどうぞ
撮らせて頂いております
[音楽]
[笑い]
日本一目指して頑張るぞ
[音楽]
bl